merci de nous rejoindre sur TV fil pour
le 78 sport 11e numéro du 78 sport 26
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale bonsoir Anthony
bonsoir Wilfrid bonsoir à tous ce soir
au menu de ce 78 sport du volleyball
Montini le Bretonneux joue actuellement
sa survie en régional une l'entraîneur
Abdelatif nichli qui est présent sur ce
plateau fera le point avec nous bonsoir
à vous bonsoir nous parlerons aussi
martio et KFU le prodige Guill en
courtois Sami benferlou revient des
championnats de France au réolé d'une
belle médaille d'argent nous nous ferons
un point avec lui sur cette satisfaction
ou peut-être déception du prodige
bonsoir à vous bonsoir et nous ferons
aussi un point sur tous les résultats du
weekend en fin d'émission WIF toutes les
images ce qu'il faut savoir ce qu'il
faut retenir en sport ce weekend à 50
ans en yeline dans le département des
yelin on commence par les arts martiaux
oui une fois n'est pas coutume on va
parler d'arts martiaux et de kunfu une
discipline plutôt méconnue avec un
leader C cantinois en la personne de
Sami benferlou vous revenez des
championnats de France où vous êtes
vice-champion de France de de kounfu
est-ce que c'est une déception ou une
satisfaction cette performance euh donc
c'est une satisfaction parce que on
partait déjà avec des objectifs précis
avec mon entraîneur donc à savoir
c'était de préparer le championnat du
monde de la meilleure façon donc
d'augmenter une note en fait parce que
les en kung fu les notes sont divisées
en en trois chapitre oui voilà c'est ça
donc le but c'était d'augmenter au
maximum la note B donc pour gonfler au
maximum pour les championnats du monde
car c'est une note qui fait vraiment la
différence et qui détermine si on est
sur le podium ou non donc l'objectif a
été rempli j'ai augmenté ma note B donc
je suis plus ou moins satisfait tant
mieux donc si vous êtes satisfait mais
avant de de débrifier plus longuement ce
championnat de France 2013 je vous
propose de regarder ce portrait que j'ai
réalisé de vous il y a quelques jours
lors de vos derniers
entraînements
lorsqu'il a poussé la porte du Dragon
Noir Le guyant courtois Sami benferlou
ne se doutait sûrement pas un jour faire
partie des 20 meilleurs mondiaux à 23
ans à quelques jours des championnats de
France de KFU le vice-champion d'Europe
répète inlassablement le Tao cette
démonstration armée d'un bâton ou d'une
épée où chaque mouvement est disséqué et
d'une rare
intensité le moindre détail a son
importance de la pose des pieds au sol à
l'angle des jambes sur la position garde
c'est habituel mais que ce soit
démonstration ou
compétition je veux pas banaliser la
chose justement et dire bah c'est bon je
l'ai déjà fait des millions de fois non
c'est que chaque compétition chaque
démonstration il faut la faire à 200 %
sinon c'est là où on peut risquer
quelque
chose on utilise les championnats de
France pour les préparations pour les
des échéances internationales donc là
par exemple on a mis au point certaines
techniques nouvelles un court décès
suffit aux jeunes Samis àors agé de 7
ans et fan des films de Bruce Lee pour
comprendre l'essens même du wouchou
plusquun art martial c'est une
philosophie de vie sur chaque coup de
nez chaque position le Guillan courtois
fait un voyage dans le temps vers des
pratiques ancestrales vieilles de
plusieurs
siècles fidèle à son entraîneur de
toujours Sami benferlou s mise désormais
dans la hiérarchie mondial dominé par
les combattants chinois dans le wouchou
plus qu'ailleurs la relation élèv
professeur est vitale et pleine de
respect on a juste un des meilleurs prof
en France en kung fu quoi donc sans lui
enin j'aurais vraiment pas pu être là où
je suis parce que bah voilà c'est une
des références dans le Kung fou français
et que sans lui sans son savoir en
jamais j'aurais pu être là où j'en suis
maintenant quoi
vraiment
voilà pour cette démonstration plutôt
impressionnante d'ailleurs notre autre
invité avec qui on va parler volet tout
à l'heure est resté bougeb he devant la
démonstration ah oui oui c'est c'est
impressionnant c'est précis c'est c'est
rapide comme préparation pour un match
de volet pour la concentration
l'exactitude des gestes pourquoi pas oui
on est on n pas tout à fait dans le même
registre mais je pense que enfin il y a
il y a beaucoup de concentration sur ça
pourrait impressionner les adversaires
avant les rencontres
tout à fait d' h au volet peut-être de H
d'ailleurs si vous voulez faire une
petite démonstration un bon match à
Montini vous êtes bienvenus ça pourrait
éventuellement et bien voilà j'ai passé
exactement alors vous en disiez un mot
tout à l'heure Sami c'était ces
championnats de France c'était un
rendez-vous pour préparer évidemment les
les Championnat du Monde 2013 en octobre
à kualalumpour en Malaisie qui est votre
vrai rendez-vous en final de de cette
saison voilà enfin c'est là où j'ai
vraiment vraiment envie de performer et
donc d'atteindre soit le podium soit le
top 5 mondial et améliorer mes
performances de de l'année dernière au
championnat au dernier championnat du
monde et alors comment vous avez fait
justement pour essayer d'améliorer
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
travaillez à l'entraînement et puis
qu'est-ce que vous avez essayé pendant
ces championnats donc ça va être des
mouvements qu'on a comme il a dit
Stéphane donc c'est des mouvements qu'on
a changé des innovations
euh vu que c'est un taolou c'est
plusieurs mouvements vont être associés
et donc il faut que comment dire il y a
plus de 200 personnes qui vont passer au
championnat du monde il faut voilà il
faut se démarquer il faut montrer sa
petite touche personnelle ne pas dire
bah je copie les Chinois qui sont les
qui sont la référence en kung fu et
quelle touche personnelle on peut
apporter parce que c'est aussi très
codifié il y a des choses très précises
à respecter donc donc ça va être des
mouvements qui sortent du traditionnel
de de de l'essence même du kung fu on
retourne vraiment à la base et ça peut
être quoi un coup de pied circulaire
pour essayer de se se faire une image PE
un saut ce ch ça peut être un saut par
exemple le saut que j'ai fait tout à
l'heure dans le reportage où je tombe
par terre bah par exemple ça c'est enfin
les juris ils apprécie parce que c'est
c'est pas commun tous les athlètes
mondiaux ne le font enfin non pas que ce
soit difficile mais c'est ma petite
touche personnelle vous vous entraîner
combien d'heures par semaine pour
préparer les championnats du monde ça va
de à peu près 10 10 heur par par semaine
tous les jours 2h à peu près c'est assez
exigeant ouai tout à fait alors pour
arriver donc sur cette marche parce que
vous visez évidemment un top 5 peut-être
un podium à ces mondes là est-ce que il
y a des des des choses à ne pas manquer
justement lors de lors d'une épreuve
comme ça comme le Tao qui est une sorte
de kata en fait pour pour donner donc il
faut pas louper les sauts les difficulté
donc c'est c'est le groupe C qui va
arbitrer ça donc c'est un peu comme en
gymnastique on va avoir des on a des
saut à réaliser des difficultés et donc
les arbitres vont noter ça donc ça c'est
noté sur deux donc ça il faut avoir deux
ensuite il y a la note A c'est tout ce
qui est technique c'est les bases c'est
les bases du kung fu les positions
position des des
pieds des cuisses tout ça donc ça pareil
c'est sur 5 il faut avoir 5 faut partir
sur 5 et 2 ensuite c'est la note B qui
fait la différence qui est noté sur 3 où
il faut taper sur du 265 270 c'est
l'objectif pour moi pour ces prochains
mondes alors c championat de France
c'était une formalité pour vous parce
que je rappelle un peu votre palmarès
vous avez 17 titres nationaux donc
évidemment il avoir une belle collection
à la maison mais alors cheminée
justement quand on est autant de fois
champion de France notamment dans dans
votre cas est-ce que on a des pressions
on va dire du staff de l'équipe de
France pour essayer d'aller encore
chercher plus haut et de bah de
bousculer ses chinois au final voilà
donc ils vont attendre des des choses
précises ils veulent qu'on prenne des
risques qu'on aille plus vite que ce
soit par exemple en bâton si bah faut
que j'aille aussi vite que possible donc
il y a un risque que le bâton casse donc
s'il casse bah c'est un risque à prendre
mais derrière s'il casse pas au moins je
serai deux fois plus rapide que les
autres compétiteurs donc c'est des sur
ces petits détails là que ça va se se
jouer quoi alors là après ces
championnats de France où vous êtes o
vous êtes vicechampion il y a un petit
peu de vacances un peu de repos vous
êtes déjà reparti à l'entraînement
aujourd'hui non ça sera demain mais ça
sera sur un rythme un peu plus doux et
il y a un programme spécifique justement
pour ces championnats du monde là en OCT
voilà donc à partir de la semaine
prochaine ça va recommencer donc sur une
base de physique pour augmenter le
physique et et ensuite on on dévirera
vers le technique encore et encore et
pour au final bousculer les Chinois
dit pour enfin s'imposer dans ce top 5
et voir le podium merci beaucoup Sami
d'être venu ce soir sur le plateau de
TVfil et puis on suivra donc c'est ces
Championnat du Monde fin d'année merci
beaucoup encore avec nous bien sûr
puisque le 78 sport se poursuit on va
parler volet dans un instant avec notre
autre invité qui est sur ce plateau
entraîneur des seniors de laasb de
Montini le Breton auparavant l'c trail
c'était ce weekend oui ce weekend les
trailers avaient rendez-vous à la base
de loisir de 50 ans en Eveline pour la
6e édition de l'chotrail avec Patrick
Jacques de dixm nous avons voulu voir
justement comment ils appréhendent ces
80 km c'est long 80 km de cette course
écoresponsable
embouteillage sur la ligne de départ de
l'ecchotraail ils étaient près de 8000 à
sé lancé de plusieurs sites francilien
pour rejoindre la Tour Eiffel ce samedi
sur l'épreuve reine de 80 km au départ
de la base de loisir de 50 ans en Evelin
les concurrents se préparent à un effort
d'une extrême intensité bah c'est la
première fois que je vais le faire j'ai
déjà fait 67 km sur le trail de
Chevreuse peur oui parce qu'on est
jamais sûr du résultat peur de décevoir
surtout mais peur de mais une grosse
envie plutôt d'y arriver voilà quelques
années je sais pas moi peut-être 40 ans
d'entraînement mais je continue toujours
et ça me plaît autant oui on vient de
course on a fait le déplacement exprès
pour la pour faire cette course on l'
déjà fait l'année dernière on a ét
obligé d'abandonner au 40e km pour cause
des cloc la plart entraî exclusivement
pour cette course depuis 3 mois par dose
d'une centaine de kilomètres par semaine
sur une distance aussi longue le trailer
doit surtout gérer son alimentation mais
aucun papier par terre sur le parcours à
chacun sa pochette poubelle et sa tasse
écologique c'est aussi ça l'échotrail
pour moi le trail ça ça rime un peu avec
écologie c'est pour moi les les trailurs
doivent aimer la nature et et donc c'est
le fait que soit écologique c'est c'est
un plus au terme des 80 km syv en 5h 48
minutes et 58
secondes on passe au volet Montini qui
lutte pour son maintien en régional oui
Abdelatif nichli est avec nous ce soir
sur ce plateau alors c'est vrai comme le
disait Wilfried cette saison Montini
lutte pour pour le maintien en régional
une d'ailleurs je vous propose de voir
le classement de de ces playdown cette
phase de barrage pour ne pas descendre
après 5 matchs joués vous êtes bah 3e de
de cette poule au classement provisoire
pour l'instant voilà on le voit qui qui
s'affiche donc conflan de est en tête
avec 19 points vézii et puis puis
Montini à 15 points est-ce que justement
l'équipe appréhende un peu plus
sérieusement cette phase de cette phase
de barrage euh oui ça c'est sûr on
appréhende plus sérieusement parce que
enfin l'enjeu est quand même
important donc enfin on a déjà connu ça
par le dans le passé jouer le le couteau
sous la gorge parce que il y a il y a 4
ans on est monté de de quand on est
monté de R3 en R2 al 2 on avait enfin on
a joué le dernier match donc l'équipe
qui gagnait monta l'équipe qui enfin qui
perdait restait en division inférieure
donc ça la pression ENF on a on a on a
un peu d'expérience pareil pour l'année
dernière donc ça s'est joué jusqu'au
bout on a on avait le coute encore
surous la gorge juste jusqu'à la fin de
la saison la dernière journée on savait
pas si on si on descendait ou pas voilà
donc je pense qu'à ce niveau-là jein les
gars je leur fais confiance ils sont ENF
ils sont conscients de l'EN jeu et
euh je pense que mentalement ils sont
ils sont prêts ilst qu'est-ce qui
explique justement que vous êtes arrivé
dans cette situation et que ce soit
souvent en plus pour pour votre équipe
de se retrouver à jouer avec le couteau
sous la gorge vos joueurs sont meilleurs
avec le couteau sous la gorge non non
non c'est pasou mieux avec la pression
non c'est pas ça bon l'année dernière
bon c'était une saison transitoire donc
enfin il y a eu quelques changements
et et cette saison enfin cette année
c'est un peu c'est un peu différent
parce
que la Ligue a fait une
formule enfin un peu un peu un peu
nouvelle en fait un peu nouvelle
compliquée et
entre guillemets on est nous sommes les
victimes en fait de cette formule là
parce que en alors là accrochez-vous he
pour compr alors comment fonctionne
cette formule rester avec nous pendant
une dizaine de minutes faut faut pas
décrocher là alors c'est simple donc ils
ont fait deux poules ils ont fait deux
poules donc à la fin ils ont enfin on a
joué des des des matchs àer retour et à
la fin de du du championnat donc ils ont
pris les quatre de chaque poule donc les
quatre premières de chaque poule ils ont
fait les play-offs et les quatre
dernières ils ont fait les les
play jusque là ça va alors seulement les
équipes gardent conservent les les
points qu'ils ont gagné contre les
équipes qui sont aussi dans qui sont qui
sont aussi dans la poule d'accord
doncésavantager comm voilà ça peut
désavantager des équipes comme nous qui
qui avont gagné contre des équipes de
haut tableau donc les équipes de haut
tableau ils sont en play-off donc du
coup on n pas récupéré le on n pas
récupéré les points qu'on a gagné contre
ces équipes là c'est très très compliqué
comme formule on aurait pu imaginer que
comp àé pour voilà c'est compliqué c'est
ça ça ça pénalise enfin des équipes
comme nous qui voilà enfin on ne peut
pas être à la hauteur tout le temps on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas être bon tout
le temps on peut pas avoir le tout tout
son effectif tout le temps il y a des
blessures il y a des voilà et
malheureusement bah voilà il faut faut
faut plutôt se concentrer sur les
équipes de son niveau au lieu enfin au
lieu de de tout donner contre les
équipes de tableau des cou vraiment
pendant la saison de s'imposer sur des
grosses équipes si au final on retrouver
à jouer maintien il faut mieux voilà
réaliser une bonne opération sur équip
de même tout ça bah oui donc du coup
enfin voilà c'estf y a plein de clubs
qui sont pas contents de cette formu là
je pense pas qu'il la conserve l'année
prochaine en attendant il faudra faire
avec pour essayer d'assurer ce maintien
exactement faut faire avec et donc du
coup à l'URE actuelleentra quel est
l'état d'esprit vous vous dites quoi vos
joueurs plaisir cohésion on essaie de de
regrouper les les joueurs autour d'une
même valeur un peu un peu de plaisir
donc là ces derniers temps on a on a
lâché un peu enfin on a levé un peu le
pied sur sur la rigur l'entraînement
sérieuse et tout ça donc on a profité de
de la
trêve des des vacances donc ça a été
plutôt voilà donc des entraînement basé
sur beaucoup de jeux beaucoup de
beaucoup de plaisir donc là ça enin les
choses sérieuses prennent à partir de de
demain on s'entraîne demain on a on a un
match de de coupe des iblines Judi ça
nous permettra de de voir justement
voilà de de voir l'état d'esprit des
joueurs si voilà s'il sont S sont remis
dans le bain après cette petite trêve où
il y a encore voilà le le enfin le le la
pression qui pèse encore malgré ces de
semaines de de vacances et justement
après cette coupure comment vous voyez
la fin là de ces playdown la
fin je je me vois encore en regional en
regiginal une moi je voilà moi je j'ai
confiance on va on va tout faire pour
pour se
maintenir donc donc voilà confiance ou
et faites appel à Sami viendra faire une
petite démonstration je vous le dis
avant le match ça va impressionner les
joueurs adverses et vous allez gagner
petite démonstration pour pour pour
voilà venez donner un coup de main à
cette équipe de Montini vous le disiez
tout à l'heure pour vous avez plusieurs
fois échappé de peu à la descente votre
votre équipe elle est un peu en
reconstruction à l'image du club non
c'est un peu ça là il y il y a des
choses nouvelles qui se mettent en place
comme vous dis tout à fait il y a des
choses nouvelles qui qui se mettent en
place sous la direction du du président
Siri Blanchin on est en train de
restructurer un peu le le le le club
donc là cette année on a tenté une
expérience de formation de d'entraîneurs
c'est la première fois qu'on forme des
entraîneurs au club avec un un
intervenant extérieur extérieur du du
département c'est le conseil technique
département mental euh on a formé cinq
entraîneurs et
euh au niveau des jeunes pareil on a on
a des formations d'arbitrees donc voilà
on ESS on essaie de restructurer les
jeunes on leur a rajouté des séances de
de de enfin d'entraînement voilà et euh
donc voilà on essaie
de plel
d'élement voilà mais mais voilà mais il
est important aussi de de garder l'image
du club en l'occurrence l'équipe une qui
voilà qui qui doit se maintenir enfin on
n pas on n pas le choix pour justement
accompagner C tous ces changements et
voilà on suivra de près C ces derniers
matchs de barrage Abdelatif et puis on
espère que que montinis se maintienne en
régional une merci à vous merci
également à notre autre invité qui était
sur ce plateau Sami benferlou donc et
votre actualité c'est Championnat du
Monde en octobre 2013 de kfou que vous
préparez très activement on a pu le voir
merci à tous les deux Anthony on
poursuit on s'intéresse au football à
présent football féminin lors de la 17e
journée de de Division 2 Montini avait
l'occasion de se rapprocher du podium en
cas de victoire face à Amien à 5 journée
de la fin du championnat le club
yimontain prépare déjà la saison
prochaine recrutement staff et ambition
état des lieux avec Patrick Jacques de
dixmud à Montini l'heure est à la
reconstruction arrivé l'été dernier
l'entraîneur jean-dani Grosset a
récupéré un groupe très jeune le
maintien assuré à 5 journées de la fin
du championnat de Division 2 les
inimontaines peuvent désormais viser
plus haut allez le challenge dé F c'est
finir de qu premier en sachant que
ninbaumont est leader incesté qui va et
va monter va monter en en D1 donc c'est
de finir on a des matchs des matchs
intéressants et on peut on peut se
rendre la fin de saison agréable à jouer
et à se faire plaisir pour le GR pour ce
groupe qui est jeune le staff inimontain
se projette à moyen terme et prépare
déjà la saison prochaine recherche de
sponsors et de recru l'objectif est
affiché la montée en première division
mais en attendant les coéquipières de
Margot Robin recevaient ce weekend
l'avant-dernier à mien une rencontre
dominée de bout en bout j Sanson ouvre
le score en fixant parfaitement la
gardienne sur cet intérieur du
gauche grâce à un doublé de Margot Robin
les ctinois s'imposent finalement qu
buts à deux et deviennent la bête noire
des amiennoises avec trois victoires en
autant de match avec ce succès les
inimontaines pointent toujours à la 7e
place mais à seulement TR points du
podium
en football espérons que ce soit le
dernier weekend de de report à cause des
forts chutes de neige en milieu de
semaine de nombreuses rencontres n'ont
pas pu avoir lieu en Division d'Honneur
notamment et en promotion d'honneur mais
en football féminin cela a joué en
promotion de ligue et l'encours continue
sans sans faute les Amazones se sont
imposés à poissi 4 buts à z0ro après 13
journées les joueuses de danigle sont
évidemment en tête avec 48 points et
n'ont enquissé que buts depuis le début
de la saison autre résultat du du foot
féminin au hand féminin 18e journée de
de Nationale 2 les féminines de Montini
se déplaçai à Gan en en scène Saint- N
et pour la première fois de la saison
les joueus de Stéphane paysan ont
enchaîné une 4e victoire consécutive en
s'imposant 34 à 27 grâce notamment à
cette réalisation de Cécile Bisel avec
ce succès les coéquipières de Gabriel
parloer remontent du coup à la 4e place
avec 40 points à 10 longueurs du leader
Rennais mathématiquement tout est encore
jouable Wilfried pour la montée à 4
journées de la fin du championnat basket
est tr toujours menacé par la relégation
même si rien est joué encore mais ça
devient compliqué ça devient très très
compliqué chez les hommes donc trappe s
incliné sur son parquet face à Vitré 70
à 53 les traapistes sont toujours 13e et
avant-dernier de National 2 de leur côté
les féminines de l'Entente le chaîn
versa se sont imposés de justesse à
domicile 68 à 67 face au PO sononnet
avec cette victoire les joueuses de vin
Bardic restent leader à égalité de
points avec bourg beaucoup de résultats
ce weekend du tennis de table à présent
5e journée de National 2 de voisin
saint-arnou recevait l'avant-dernier
périgé les joueus de geoffrénisan ont dû
se battre jusqu'au bout et jusqu'au
dernier match pour s'imposer pourtant
avant les doubles les cinquentinoises
avaient fait le break et menaient 5
matchs à trois ce n'est qu'à 7p partout
que Salomé la porta redonne l'avantage
aux cinquentinoises qui s'impose
finalement 10 matchs à H8 dans les
autres matchs de cette poule de National
2 hlancour est allé chercher le match
nul chez le 3è fonttenit 9 matchs
partout mais lespongistes é enctoises ne
gagnent plus hein depuis la première
journée au classement de cette poussée
l'entente voisin saint-arnou est
toujours 2e et grignote un petit point
sur le leader jouer les tours tenu en
échec à Poitier et l' encours de son
côté reste 5e et devra encore se battre
pour le maintien alors que se profile le
superbe derby cquantinois dans ce
championnat de lors de la lors de la
prochaine journée pardon le 6 avril dont
nous aurons bien sûr l'occasion de
reparler au cours du prochain 78 sport
ETL encour qui réalise pour l'instant un
sans faute sur ce début de saison en
footu oui trois journées trois victoires
tout simplement un peu moins aisé cette
fois-ci ils les templi des l cours se
sont imposés chez les Black Panthers de
Tenon les Bains 28 à 20 avec trois
victoires en journée évidemment les
joueurs d'Emmanuel Charet sont
naturellement leader et ils sont
forcément très satisfaits les
précédentes saisons avaient été
compliquées celle-ci se déroule plutôt
bien merci Anthony on se retrouve lundi
prochain toujours en même horaire pour
une nouvelle édition du 78 sport oui
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à le commenter
ce 78 sport sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag le 78 sport tout attaché et
nous donner tous les résultats de vos
clubs à lundi prochain bonne
soirée